c'est le port de sortie d'urine où vous
auriez la sortie pour les
tuyaux d'urine auraient été ceux-ci ont été fabriqués
pour une fois utilisés pour se rendre sur la lune et
revenir les matériaux étaient tous nouveaux dans les
années 1960 pour une utilisation temporaire, nous savons que les
vessies en caoutchouc étaient  censés
durer seulement six mois et ils ont duré maintenant
cinquante ans, alors où nous espérons les
conserver pendant encore 50 ans,
vous verrez comme un peu de
jaunissement ici sur le tissu blanc,
vous pourriez voir un effilochage du
le matériau qui convient en fait dans un très
bon état car pour un costume celui-ci
n'a pas marché sur la surface lunaire, nous l'avons donc
fait, il n'a pas été aussi utilisé que les
costumes Aldrin et Armstrong, par exemple, les
gants sont vraiment la partie la plus
difficile d'un  scaphandre à concevoir
car les doigts sont
tellement délicats mais tellement indispensables aux
activités humaines la poussière lunaire est tellement agressive
que si vous prenez une vue microscopique
du chrome lr ce
tissu inox vous trouverez des granulés  ou lunaire
fait intégré et vous érodez à
travers les fibres qu'ils grognent ces
fibres d'acier inoxydable que
vous